[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists danny unknown get
that tick-tock machine ready because i
have a question for everyone
what's one thing that you've purchased
that you soon regretted
seriously let me know one thing in the
comments because today we're talking
about consumer regrets and buyer's
remorse on the minimalist podcast why
well
because we often buy things that we
think we want just to find out that the
things we want aren't actually the
things
we want
then this thursday on the minimalist
private podcast ryan and i are going to
talk about our own personal consumer
regrets we'll ask our team to open up
about their
consumer regrets and we'll turn to our
audience to hear about myriad other
types of buyers remorse plus ryan
now that the smoke has cleared
we're going to argue
about will smith slapping chris rock
during the oscars my goodness and we're
going to talk about all the backlash
that the minimalist received recently on
social media on two separate occasions
this week you can check that out at
patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
alabama looks like we got a question
here from holly on facebook
what good does regret do for us is it
just another form of destructive
attachment or is there some sort of
benefit
ryan we we're attached to regret i don't
know i don't know if regret i mean
ultimately yes it is some sort of
attachment
i don't know how destructive it is and
so i when i saw this question from holly
i started looking into are there any
benefits of
regret yeah and i actually found
something from the nih
and i printed this out a couple
different studies about regret i was
really shocked by this let me read this
as a jump off point we usually do this
on the maximal episode but i thought
this was a perfect answer to her
question you and i can talk about it
what do people think about the emotion
of regret recent demonstrations of the
psychological benefits of regret have
been framed against an assumption that
most people find regret to be adversive
both when experienced but also when
later recalled two studies explored lay
evaluations of regret experiences
revealing them to be largely favorable
rather than unfavorable
study one demonstrated that regret but
not other negative emotions was
dominated by positive
more than negative emotions
in both studies number one and two
although participants saw a great deal
of benefit in their negative emotions
regret stood out as particularly
beneficial indeed in study 2 regret was
seen to be the most beneficial of the 12
negative
emotions man ryan and it goes on to say
uh why it's beneficial so in short
people value their regret substantially
more than they do other negative
emotions
here's why and it goes into one of the
studies here regret triggers behavior
change aimed at remediation so when we
regret something
we often change the behavior that led to
the regret right and i think quite often
the other negative emotions like stress
or anxiety we don't make any change or
if we do it doesn't affect the stress or
anxiety as much as the regret yeah and
finally it says in other words
information gleaned from regrets can
guide future behavior aimed at achieving
achieving desired outcomes yeah
man uh well you know tony robbins talks
about when you have a strong emotion
attached with an action like that is um
like a really good way to change your
state so i could see where regret would
totally be
a useful emotion because yes when you
feel negative
um i mean that's
that's what we do with our lives josh we
are running away from pain
and discomfort so you know the more
discomfort we experience the more we
want to get away from it so when you do
something and you regret it you feel
that pain
and that pain triggers some sort of
change within you right it's like you
don't want to re-experience that that
regret and here's the thing about regret
too is
it you know regret is first off it's
silly to moralize regret it's not good
or bad it's just regret yes so um it all
depends on how you're using it and if
you use it to learn a lesson then that's
valuable but if you're using regret to
uh beat yourself up with that regret is
going to turn into guilt and then that
guilt will turn into shame
so in that sense
regret not so useful but if we use it to
learn something that's really where the
power is yeah so if you're holding on to
the regret not making any changes not
learning the lesson from the regret i
think the opposite of that
is fascinating as well because people
often talk about how do i let go of the
regret i think we're going to be talking
about that on this episode as well in
fact let's move on to our callers here
if you have a question or a comment for
our podcast give us a call 406-219-7800
or email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com it looks like we have
a question here from mike in schaumburg
illinois what if you donate something to
charity and then you think about
purchasing that product again
what's behind that
so ryan mike is asking about the regret
of letting go of something
but then oh i'm thinking about buying
this again yeah now it seems to me there
are a few reasons that we would think
about that let's say i went and donated
our tool kit which is useful and we use
it every day sure
well that was a mistake i by letting go
of that i'm actually depriving myself of
something useful yeah and so that might
be one reason that you're like oh hey i
got rid of this thing that i actually
found useful it didn't make sense it
didn't benefit me to get rid of it yeah
i've done that with a blender yeah
whereas like yeah mariah and i were
moving and i'm like we don't really use
this blender we didn't really need it we
got rid of it and then about six months
later there was like you know three four
or five times where i was like man i
really wish we had a blender uh-huh um
so yeah i mean yes i think in order to
decide whether or not something is
useful you can totally you know look at
the the minimalist rule book that we
have which is really just a minimalist
boundaries book um it's also on our book
love people use things
and you know you can ask yourselves
these questions to see if it's something
that you actually are going to miss
sometimes things have a season though
you know
so
maybe maybe you buy something it's
really uh important to you at the time
you're using it and then you you don't
use it for a couple years so you look at
that rule book and you're like oh man
this like totally like if i take the
seasonality rule yes this is uh you know
i have i used in the last 90 days am i
going to use it in the next 90 days uh
if i answer no to that i'm going to let
it go or the spontaneous combustion rule
hey uh
this thing spontaneously combusted would
i replace it and if i'm answering no to
those questions then i'm giving myself
permission to let go right but then you
know two years from then it might be
something that i need to bring back in
my into my life for whatever reason yeah
and i think it's okay to realize that
you might need it
you might need to bring it back into
your life it there may be a season where
it's not useful and so you're
essentially putting it in a storage
locker that you don't have to pay for in
a way what i mean by that is like let's
say it is a blender yeah uh the example
that comes to mind is we were in
albuquerque and this guy said hey every
time i need a chainsaw i need it like
once a year
that maybe i'll i'll i'll buy it from
craigslist and then i'll put it back in
the storage locker craigslist right so
someone else has access to it and then
the next time i need a chainsaw i'll go
there and i'll i'll do that again now
obviously there are certain things like
that you could even rent so you don't
have to hold on to them in perpetuity
it's not that you should hold on to
certain things or you should let go of
certain things mike if you haven't
checked out the rulebook it's the
minimalists.com rulebook but those rules
are basically some parameters it's free
you can download it there's 16 different
rules for living with less in there but
they're not really rules they're
boundaries that are completely
adjustable for you whatever season of
life that you're in now let's talk about
where else that regret might be coming
from that feeling of oh i shouldn't have
gotten rid of that so we talked about
hey if it's useful
obviously i didn't want to let go of the
thing in the first place right now we
have to be careful because we can
justify we can pretend anything's useful
we get confused and think oh this this
junk item you know i'll hold on to it
just in case which is one of the 16
rules for living with less the the just
in case rule however the other side of
this is hey i got rid of the thing
and now i'm thinking about it because
other people in the culture have that
same thing
so maybe you got rid of your
expensive car you were driving a lexus
and you downgraded to a toyota like i
did right and all of a sudden you see
lexus is everywhere as soon as you got
rid of your lexus it's like oh man in
the the heated seats and
and we we over value the things that
other people have and then we get the
things that those people have and
realize it doesn't have the value that
we thought that it had in the first
place yeah oh you could tick-tock that
danny whenever i mean whenever you're
purchasing
anything for you know to impress someone
else or to make yourself look a certain
way to someone else
um
you know that's that is a
dangerous road to go down because
certainly there are times like if i'm
going to court i'm going to want to wear
a suit right so like there is a there's
something that you know i want to um
i want to put on or wear to like show
respect or whatever it is um you know i
used to go to like i get invited to
weddings and i would wear like my zero
shoes and my shorts and like a t-shirt
and it was more of a statement of like
hey i'm not going to buy a suit just
just because i have to go to a wedding
once a year
but then
you know kind of looking back on it i'm
like
ryan you're kind of a jerk man like you
know like you you're you're there to
honor the bride in the groom
and not not that anyone was ever
offended but i wasn't going out of my
way to like you know show respect for
that specific event so there are times
where it's appropriate is what i'm
trying to say yeah but if it's but if
it's a virtue signaling well yeah i'm
gonna i'm gonna bring that rolex back
into my life because you know i see more
and more people wearing them i mean
that's where it might be a little bit of
a dangerous path to go down right
because it's never-ending as well so you
get the dream
the dream job the dream car the dream
house and those things turn into a
nightmare as soon as you've acquired the
dream what happens it'd be great if you
acquired the dream
and it satisfied all of your desires and
you felt wonderful you felt fulfilled
but what happens new bigger
better dreams pop up
the five bedroom mcmansion isn't doing
it i need the six bedroom seven bath
mcmansion
it never stops until you identify what
is enough
for you yeah and so really when we're
talking to mike what we're talking to
him about is you feel like you don't
have enough yeah and that's why you feel
like oh i'm incomplete i need to bring
this thing back in did it complete you
before mike
of course the thing didn't complete you
before now let's be honest if it added
value to your life
wonderful
then don't deprive yourself of that
maybe temporarily deprive yourself
because that will teach you whether or
not it actually added value
but if you're feeling the remorse
instead of
figuring out should i buy the thing
should i not buy the thing
ask yourself
why
do i feel that remorse
do i feel incomplete without the thing
and if so will that thing complete me
and of course you know the answer to
that now mike great news we're going to
be in
chicago this month and i'd love to give
you a couple tickets so podcast john if
you could reach out to mike give him two
tickets to our chicago event now y'all
we'd love to have this event sell out so
if you're anywhere in the midwest we're
going to be in chicago and minneapolis
these are the last two stops for the
american version of the love people use
things tour ryan gives a minimalism talk
i do a book reading from our book love
people use things but then the best part
a live version of the minimalist podcast
in front of an audience where you get to
participate in the podcast so mike come
on out we'll be in chicago we'll give
you a couple tickets for that or if
you're in minneapolis or anywhere in the
midwest make that road trip we'd love to
see you there we'll also be in toronto
and vancouver later this year to finish
off the love people use things tour and
ryan we should probably mention since we
have a hundred of these
if you need to connect with open-minded
people locally we have
these free local meetup groups so say
you can't make it to one of our live
events you want to connect with some
open-minded people we have something
called minimalist.org yeah
minimalist.org
you can find free local meetup groups
eight countries a hundred different
cities including an online city if you
can't make it to even any of those
meetups yeah now that people are finally
meeting again it's a great place to meet
some open-minded people to talk about
minimizing simple living career clutter
financial clutter all these different
types of clutter that are that are in
our lives yeah i mean man the pandemic
is like finally uh
loosening up a little bit to where
people are starting to meet back in
person yeah so um yeah minimalist.org
like people are getting together and
they're talking about all things simple
uh some of them are still doing like
zoom only meetings but still in most of
the cities there is a way to connect
with a group of open-minded people now
if you go to like one of the cities and
it says hey sorry there's not a
community leader for this city so that
means if there's no leader there's no
events being planned you could totally
step up and lead in your city you can
just shoot us an email and then there's
a real there's a link it's real easy
real intuitive um but yeah it's really
exciting like just to see um just seeing
people get back together and like yeah
and these these groups are it's amazing
and you're doing a monthly theme with
those right now as well yeah so right
now uh april we're doing simple living
so that's a pretty broad topic
it's a great place to start because with
the monthly themes and then we'll get
more specific you know go into calendar
clutter
financial clutter relationship clutter
doing a monthly theme when when you're
meeting so if you want to connect with
some open-minded people some like-minded
people locally minimalist.org find the
city closest to you mike enjoy those
tickets to the love people use things
for if anyone else wants to go the
minimalists.com
tour to find chicago minneapolis toronto
and vancouver you can also find
recordings of past live events including
the magical new york city event we just
did oh with golden oh seth godin and tk
coleman ntk yeah one of the most magical
nights we've ever had the
minimalists.com tour to find the city's
nearest you and recordings of previous
events alabama do you have any questions
or comments how about some regrets from
the live stream shout out to our patreon
supporters who tune in during the live
stream each week
we have a few regrets uh from yaman
before embarking on my journey of
becoming debt free i leased a jeep that
was my biggest consumer mistake everyone
told me not to and i justified it every
which way just to do it
man but it's there's something wrong
with leasing a jeep right again we're
not trying to moralize anything here but
it sounds like uh he could not afford it
and or uh or maybe he lost a little bit
of money on it yeah and oh man i don't
even want to talk about the
you know the new toyota i brought i
bought every couple years because my in
my in my
mind my simple mind
every time i needed like major work done
on a car
when it was going to be a couple
thousand dollars i'm like i'm just going
to trade it in
i have to put anything down there's
equity in this one i'll just move it
over to this one and instead of spending
two thousand dollars now i'll just get
this you know 200 or 300 a month payment
and uh that made total sense to me until
i think it's like when i bought my my
third new
toyota
um
that's that's one of the things that i
felt regret with and i learned like hey
man like if i would have just stuck with
that first one it'd be paid off i'd have
no monthly payment
and uh yeah i had to learn a lesson the
hard way but man i'll tell you what you
go to that dealership and you sit in a
new car and they give you the keys
they're like have fun and it's got the
new car smell
and this one at bluetooth i mean that
was like i don't know why but for some
reason that was the one reason
why i got the car was the bluetooth in
hindsight i'm like i could have just got
a stereo with you know replace my stereo
with bluetooth and instead of you know
spending 30 grand or 35 grand on this
car it's the most expensive bluetooth
adapter ever gosh dude i was talking to
danny about this beforehand danny
unknown he does all of our tick tock and
he's actually running the audio right
now while podcast sean
is out today
don't worry mike podcast sean will
listen to this and get you your uh your
tickets
anyway uh danny he had to upgrade his
phone recently because his phone just
kept power cycling over and over and he
couldn't use it anymore it was rendered
useless it was a paperweight basically
and
the thing he avoided doing which i
thought was a wonderful little tip for
folks is he didn't go into the store he
didn't go into the iphone dealership
because that's what it is oh man all
that new phone smell in there it really
is and he was like i knew i know i
didn't want to invest that's another one
where we used to invest
in the iphone 13 pro because we can
justify just about anything you get to
that dealership you can justify buying a
new car because you don't have bluetooth
you can justify buying the most
expensive iphone just because your last
one stopped working even though it you
don't need all the extra features
necessarily now if you do be honest with
yourself but also be honest with
yourself if you're justifying
oh yeah you know what i'm going to be
able to use this all the behind the
scenes footage i'm going to be able to
shoot with this new iphone pro right
it's going to make me a better
photographer i'm going to use this gear
whatever no no no no no creativity
is birthed
from limitations
so constraining yourself temporarily
actually makes you more creative you can
have the most expensive pin from mont
blanc or whatever you buy a thousand
dollar pin yeah you're not gonna write
better stories with it the same is true
with a car with an iphone with a suit
with a pair of jeans no matter what it
is that item is not going to make you a
better version of you it's not going to
make your activity better necessarily
however
if you feel as though you're depriving
yourself
great what are you learning from that
deprivation
why do i actually need this can i get by
without it and
will my art or my creativity actually be
improved without making the upgrade
without making the purchase
yeah man i cannot wait
to talk on the maximal about the
statement we made about car payments
that drove people wild oh by the way
we're not intentionally trying to piss
anybody off just a heads up
we just did we just did yeah a lot of
people yeah and so yeah we'll talk about
the maximal ryan before we get into the
lightning round i've printed out this
article about buyer's remorse by the way
everything we're talking about today
we'll put in the show notes so the
studies that i read earlier podcast john
we'll throw those in the show notes and
this is just talking about the sort of
broader definition and understanding of
buyer's remorse we'll put a link to this
wikipedia page in the show notes as well
buyer's remorse so we're talking about
consumer regrets obviously
buyer's remorse is another way to put
that buyer's remorse is the sense of
regret
after having made a purchase it is
frequently associated with the purchase
of an expensive item such as a vehicle
or real estate or an iphone
or an expensive suit or a wedding dress
or there's a bunch of things we'll talk
about on the maximal that we have a lot
of regrets for our audiences has talked
about their regrets and also danny and
jordan and alabama are here they can
talk about their regrets as well i
already know alabama's and uh you'll
want to hear it it's funny
all right buyer's remorse is thought to
stem from cognitive dissonance
specifically post-decision dissidence
that arises when a person must make a
difficult decision such as a heavily
invested purchase between two similarly
appealing alternatives factors that
affect buyer's remorse may include
resources invested i.e money time
attention worrying about the thing right
the involvement of the purchaser whether
the purchase is compatible with the
purchaser's goals i would say or their
values right
feelings encountered post purchase
that include regret so
so you may not experience the regret
when you're buying it but when you're in
the parking lot or when you get home or
when a week later when you get the
credit card a month later we get the
credit card statement
now
that regret starts to sink in what have
i done
yeah
anyway it talks about the causes here
ryan it says the remorse may be caused
by various factors such as a purchase a
person purchase a product now rather
than waiting remember layaway
oh my god that was a thing and so
it was the opposite of financing yeah it
was essentially saving for a specific
item giving your money to sears we used
to do this my mom would drive us to
middletown ohio right there was a sears
catalog store right next to the hills
department store
and we would go and put money every
friday on the thing we wanted from the
sears catalog wow and then we couldn't
get it until it was actually paid off we
didn't have a credit card right to
bring the thing home in advance isn't
that interesting because you could do
layaway by yourself just put five
dollars away in a jar every week or
whatever it is yes but uh yeah it's just
funny how we need like a third party to
like help us save that money and there i
mean there's something there that
probably is a deeper conversation but
it's just interesting to me that layaway
anyone can do lay away like girl i don't
the store to do it for you right do you
remember the piggy banks or you they
didn't have a you just put the money in
but then you had to like break it in
order to get the money out yes jerome my
brother and i uh we had one when we were
kids yeah and i remember we got it
like we put a quarter in it yeah and
then like shook it and we're like i
think there's more money in here and
immediately we just broke it up
immediately yeah and there was just a
quarter oh my goodness that's hilarious
and so that that perfectly illustrates
like our desire to get more right now
even as kids it was like i was talking
to my daughter about this last night and
i said ella have you
have you ever
regretted buying anything you brought
into your life and she said homework
now first off it's crazy they're giving
third graders homework it's a little
absurd right
in fact the new school that we're
looking at for her doesn't do homework
which
um is what i'm totally on board with
yeah um because if she's compelled to do
things that she can learn outside of
school then it doesn't feel like work in
the first place yeah like doing this
podcast with you doesn't feel like work
right it is technically our vocation
right or at least part of it
and the layaway thing is fascinating
because yeah we would go there every
friday we'd put money on the thing we
wanted to purchase
but it was rewarding our future self by
being responsible with our money going
that's the opposite we're punished
punishing our future self we're
borrowing from our future
going into debt to buy these things that
we think we need and we get that burst
of dopamine that pleasure in fact i had
this essay here from kapil gupta i'm not
going to read the whole thing and i
can't put a link to it because it's a
private email but he said pleasure is
the poor man's way
and i'll just read a little excerpt from
here this is from kapil gupta one of my
favorite thinkers philosophers
one might call him a stoic he wouldn't
call himself that he said one chases
pleasure for a dose of good feeling he
chases pleasure because he is bored most
of all he chases pleasure because
he has not found the fountain of truth
if one finds truth everything pales in
comparison pleasure is the poor man's
way electronic addiction
socialization consumerism whatever it
may be
stopping would do nothing for him after
all what else is such a man supposed to
do he seeks a dose of feeling he does
not wish to deny himself and even if he
did deny himself this would do nothing
either
truth lies not in denying oneself truth
lies in understanding what he does not
know
understanding what one does not know
arises from a desire to understand
it's a longer essay but
what i like about this ryan when i'm
thinking about this is if you understand
that thing you think you want
you probably won't actually want it
unfortunately we tend to not understand
that 30 000 bluetooth adapter
until after the purchase right and
that's when the regret seeps in however
i will say this we get questions about
letting go of regret let me talk to you
it's simple to let go of regret regret
is the easiest negative emotion i'm
negative in quotes here
negative emotion to let go of because as
soon as you
learn the lesson from the regret yeah
you let go of the regret yeah
because you've learned the lesson now
and it's turned into something
productive i know not to do that again
and so letting go of something you do it
just drops automatically as soon as you
learn the lesson from that regret the
problem is
there's a that great lyric from drew
from parlor hawk when he said i learned
a lot of good lessons here that i choose
to forget when we forget the lessons
then we're going to make the same
mistakes that regret is going to come
back again and again if we're not
learning the lesson it's a great segue
it's the lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and your
comments to
two four six 937-202-4650 four yes
indeed those texts go to both of our
phones we respond to as many people as
we can including some folks on the
podcast now during the lightning round
this is where ryan and i do our best to
answer your questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we call them minimal maxims and
we put them in the show notes so you can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like by the way you
can find all of our minimal maxims in
one place now
minimalmaxims.com ryan we have a
question from lauren alabama
what do i do when purchasing anything
gives me buyers remorse i end up feeling
guilty for every non-essential purchase
and i don't understand why
i understand why
and it's because we get confused
we
think there are there's such a thing as
non-essential purchases and essential
purchases and that's it
yeah but there's actually three
categories we call it the no junk rule
right it's in that minimalist rule book
that we have
and the no junk rule basically says
everything you own everything you
purchase everything you want everything
you desire everything you've owned in
the past yeah every material good can
fit in one of three piles it's either
essential non-essential or it's junk
we all have basic essentials so yes
the essentials you never regret buying
something that's essential food
shelter although
you might regret buying too much of a
thing
oh i bought and ate an entire cheesecake
i certainly regret that right i bought
too big of a house i bought too
expensive of a car
and so you regret those things because
you're not regretting the essential
you're regretting the parts of those
things that are non-essential that
you're not getting value from yeah now
the non-essential things are the things
that add value to your life
but the junk are the things that
masquerade as though they add value and
the reason lauren you get confused here
you end up feeling guilty
is because you are mistaking
the non-essentials and the junk because
it's easy to do i saw it in that ad and
it looked so
essential it looked so value-adding but
then i got it
i didn't get any value from it and so if
you don't get any value from it what is
it it's junk here's my pithy answer for
you if everything is valuable
nothing is valuable preach now that's a
definition you know right by definition
if everything is has the same value then
it that's all worth functionally zero
and so we have to be careful because
you'll value something differently from
the next person so yes you might see
someone who gets immense value from that
blender or from that toaster but if you
don't eat toast then you're not going to
get the same value as someone else who
gets immense value from the toaster so
choose those characters those purchases
carefully yeah so is what you're saying
is kind of like
she is uh she's feeling guilty when she
buys junk yes yes because she feels as
though oh this is supposed to add value
to my life and then i get it yeah and i
realize it doesn't so you have to think
about it beforehand is this going to add
value to my life
is an important question we have those
five questions to ask before buying in
fact you can have it as a free wallpaper
download for your phone so anytime
you're somewhere before you make that
purchase
you can just download that we'll put a
link to that in the show notes as well
or you can just download it on our
resources page over at the
minimalists.com it's just a free
wallpaper it says all right i'm going to
ask these five questions and one of
those questions is will this add value
to my life yeah and maybe expand on that
in what ways will this add value to my
life
is this worth the money i'm going to
part with that's another one of those
questions and so asking those questions
beforehand will help you avoid the
future regret we were talking on the
live stream before we started recording
this ryan i released a novel in my 20s
published a novel called as a decade
fades it was my my first book and uh the
main character jody grafton in there
he's like a singer songwriter
tattoo laden singer songwriter and one
of the tattoos on his arm says future
regrets
on it and i feel like we all need that
tattoo in a way yeah they're to remind
us that hey this decision i'm about to
make might lead to some of these these
future regrets yeah oh man uh my pithy
answer is this
uh shame is tamed when guilt is jilted
so what does jilted mean
you could tell josh helped me edit this
uh pithy answer i i loved where you were
going with it and so i was driving here
this morning and i was uh voice
dictating trying to voice dictate uh how
to
make this pithy a i said how would this
look on a poster because you were
talking about guilt and shame and and
really i think the more accurate
description here although i think that
what you have there it looks great on a
minimal maximum image but uh
guilt or shame is tamed when guilt is
understood yes when you understand the
source of your guilt
the behaviors tend to change and then
the shame goes away on its own yes now
yeah jilt means to like let go of to
kind of walk away from
and once you understand it it's easier
to walk away from it yes
yeah well we got so much more to talk
about ryan but first real quick for
right here right now
i'm so excited to share this with you
we've been working on this for almost a
year now and we're finally announcing it
and we're announcing it through this
essay so i'm going to read this essay
for you this is our right here right now
segment on the minimalist podcast and
this essay is called
this much debt
is gross
ryan our society has a problem most
people are financially illiterate
and it's not even their fault because we
don't learn how to manage money as kids
we are easily convinced by corporations
to go into debt as young adults buying
things we don't need with money we don't
have to impress people we don't like
when we spend then we spend years mired
in the mess we've made credit card debt
student loans car payments and myriad
other ways we borrow from our future
the average indebted american household
has 97
775 dollars in non-mortgage debt
how gross is that what say that again
the average indebted american household
has 97
775 dollars
in non-mortgage related debt so a car
could be in there car credit card
student loans over three big ones
everything about your mortgage yeah
that's those are the three big that's
actually in fact it's that number is
from those three things added up
together
yes
but if we can teach students if we can
teach kids how to stay out of debt then
we can end the suffering that is
compounded by debt and that's what ryan
and i want to do today that's why the
minimalists we are partnering with
ramsey education this year in 2022
to bring the foundations in personal
finance curriculum get this
to every school in our hometown dayton
ohio every school heck yeah would you be
willing to help us
and here's what we're asking for so over
the the past decade the minimalists and
our audience have contributed to nine
philanthropic projects including
building two orphanages providing relief
to american hurricane victims
constructing in elementary school and
establishing a non-profit grocery co-op
in one of the largest food deserts in
the united states and now this year with
your help
we're going to teach
personal finance to every middle and
high school student in dayton every
middle school student every high school
student in dayton and if we reach our
forty thousand dollar goal quickly we
can expand this to other cities all
across the united states
now the foundations and personal finance
teaches students
proven money principles that will set
them up for a debt-free life
the problem is many schools don't have
the resources they need to provide this
curriculum to their students and that's
how we and you can help
you can purchase the curriculum for just
one child and it's really inexpensive or
you can do it for multiple children if
you're feeling really generous but 25
provides the curriculum for one middle
school student
45 provides the curriculum for one high
school student
and if you don't have 25 bucks or 45
bucks
then five dollars you can donate as
little as five dollars
and you can help provide the curriculum
for some students
and that's awesome could you imagine if
we had this when we were kids it'd be
the best oh it would have saved me like
10 years of like pain and anguish man
all that suffering of all the crappy
financial decisions i've made yeah so by
contributing you'll help these kids
start their adult life
the right way
and like i said we're going to try to
expand this to other schools as well
beyond the city of dayton but we're
going to start with our hometown yeah
and then we'll we'll move on beyond
there and we could really use your help
we we're not gonna make any money from
this personally in fact i got a whole
thing about this but if you want to
donate the minimalists.com
education it'll take you right to the
page there's a lot of frequently asked
questions there there's the progress bar
etc etc and seriously if you spend 70
bucks here you can provide curriculum
for one middle school student one high
school student you're literally just
going in there providing the curriculum
for a student or with a forty thousand
dollar donation
you can yeah provided for the whole city
exactly why in fact you wouldn't have to
be that do that much and here's why to
be clear the minimalist won't earn any
money from this project i just wanted to
put that out there so it doesn't sound
like we're making it i'm out
we're actually going to lose money on it
i know i'm going to explain why here in
a second every penny that you donate
literally every penny a hundred percent
will be used for student curriculum
in fact ryan and i are personally
donating 2 500 of our own money to fund
the first 100 students
so if you want to help us change the
future for these kids the
minimalists.com education if you go
there
you'll find commonly asked questions
you'll find all the details you'll find
our fundraiser progress bar and after
you donate we'll email you with updates
about the impact of your contribution
the impact that it's having on
actual students lives now ryan i want to
go through this real quick since we're
doing this we have the foundations and
personal finance curriculum i went
through this this course which by the
way it's a 13-hour course i didn't go
through the whole thing but i went
through all of the curriculum yeah
because i want to make sure that as
we're helping them create this for for
the students
that it was something i was 100 behind
because i know i'm behind dave ramsey's
method and but i want to make sure that
this is going to help and not only will
it help but i would have been interested
in this as a high schooler
because it's not here's the credits and
debits molten rock is magma like it's
actual stuff i want to want to learn
right and so here's the 13 different
things that the contents of this course
you have introduction to personal
finance you have budgeting you have
saving money you have credit versus
debit you have consumer awareness career
readiness college planning financial
services the role of insurance income
and taxes housing and real estate
investing and retirement global
economics but they do it in a way so
that's there's like really four parts to
the whole curriculum there are videos
which you know in high school you would
have much rather watch videos than just
read a bunch of textbooks right oh yeah
so you have videos for every one of
these you have student textbooks you can
follow along but the videos are the main
thing you have teachers guides and you
have activities for students so they're
actually engaged in the learning yeah 25
bucks you can bring this curriculum to a
student 45 you can bring it to a high
school student if you want to help the
minimalists.com education we'd really
really appreciate if you contribute ryan
and i rarely ask for anything for
ourselves from you
we want to help these kids
well not borrow from their future yeah
so you can brighten their future today
for 25 bucks
man thank you so much malaban what else
you got for us here are some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
hi joshua ryan this is bianca speaking
i'm calling from the netherlands i have
a tip for ryan and his double swimming
trunk dilemma and a travel tip in
general i hope
ryan told us he didn't like packing an
extra set of swimming trunks just in
case the first one got dirty on the trip
personally i like to use dr bronner's
all one kestar soap i have to add that i
am in no way shape or form affiliated
with this company
dr bronner sells
a pure kestrel liquid soap which can be
used for over 18 different purposes
you can use this to clean your face body
hair dishes laundry the whole shebang so
while you're traveling you'll only need
this soap and ryan you can hand wash
your swearing trunks
i also love this company for using
organic and certified fair trade
ingredients plus they're packaged in
recyclable bottles i really like their
philosophy on how to treat the earth and
their suppliers i think this will appeal
to many fellow minimalists i hadn't
heard a recommendation on dr bonner so
before so i hope this will help some of
you out there
hi my name is taylor and i'm from tampa
florida i was listening to the nostalgia
episode and as someone who's a younger
minimalist um i don't have a whole lot
of things necessarily but i did have a
lot of t-shirts that i had accumulated
from high school and also from college
events and they all do trigger a lot of
great memories for me but they were
really clogging up my closet
and so from the transition
after college i actually took all of the
t-shirts and cut them up and made a
no-sew blanket so i'd suggest that
anyone who has a lot of t-shirts um that
would be a useful way for them to get a
use out of them it's great size it's
small i can travel with it when i go
across the state
or when i get on
just keep all those little things that
might trigger nostalgia about an event
you went to
or about maybe a club you joined
without having the extra bulk
all right y'all before we get to our
added value segment today
here's a thoughtful comment from one of
our lovely patreon subscribers sandy
said i appreciate all the different
perspectives shared by you and your
guests it gives me hope that people from
different backgrounds and religions can
live respectfully and peacefully
together right i don't know if i talked
about this on the podcast yet but that's
pretty awesome man well sorry good what
what really blew my mind this made me
think about when she she left this
comment it made me think about we were
in washington dc recently it was me and
you and t.k coleman and ken coleman no
relation
we call them the brothers coleman but i
don't think they're related and anyway
what i realized while we were on the
stage and i didn't mention it there
although it was january 6th which was
straight in washington dc on january 6th
yeah it was two years later but still it
was a insurrection of love and joy yes
and when i realized all four of us voted
differently in the last election
and yet
we love each other
we care about each other
we're compassionate toward one another
we're loving towards
i mean i i accept
and respect
all three of you so much
not because you voted the same way as me
or i need you to vote the same way or i
need you to have the same beliefs that
becomes a prison when i need everyone
else around me to be just like me
yeah it's self-righteousness and it
makes us miserable so sandy thank you so
much for that comment she said i'm a
careful budgeter and i limit my
subscription expenses
but i finally justified ryan's only fans
[Music]
otherwise known as uh the minimalist
patreon yeah yeah sorry there are not
any uh lewd pictures on our patreon
pictures of fans
well there might be some like some of
our audience some of those fans on there
that you can talk to but that's about it
yeah the only fans you're gonna see on
there
you know when i say it out loud
she said um i justified this patreon
expense because i
i'm sure that listening to your private
podcast saves me more money than the
cost of the subscription
you know i will tell you that our
podcast jordan can testify this it
actually cures gout as well
[Laughter]
consult your doctor before subscribing
to our patreon
this has not been confirmed by the fda
ryan i have an amazing added value this
week it's my favorite album of the year
so far
there's this gal young gal named jensen
mcrae
and it's her debut album the album is
called are you happy now and this is the
the title track to it it's called
starting to get to you
because clutter and consumerism are
starting to get to a lot of our
listeners
and this album it just really stuck with
me the the whole album's beautiful this
song i think you'll especially
appreciate the lyric that really stood
out to me when she's talking about
loving you is habit forming
and i won't go on to a whole diatribe
about habits right now but it's such a
beautiful beautiful song she is such a
profoundly unique artist but she
reminded me of two other really unique
artists uh tracy chapman we all know do
you know maggie rogers
she has a great song called alaska but
i'm reminded of this video that maggie
rogers uh podcast john put a link to
this video in the show
maggie rogers at uh music school and
pharrell comes in to critique
their songs oh wow imagine how much
pressure you'd be under if pharrell
williams came in oh my goodness you'd
want to run and hide yeah anyway she
plays the song for him and you see him
listening
and you're like uh oh what's wrong and
then you just seem like
like he's bowled over with emotion
and afterward he told her this reminds
me
of the first time i heard the wu-tang
clan and you're like what this sounds
nothing she's like folk dance music in a
way
and he's like it's utterly unique i have
no way to compare this to i have no
reference range
for any when wu-tang came out like
there's nothing else you could say oh it
sounds like this it doesn't sound like
anything right and her music was similar
and then i heard
i heard this song from jensen mcrae
it's called starting to get to you and
it reminded me of that where it was
profoundly unique
by the way ryan we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week like
what are josh and ryan's top three
personal consumer regrets what are the
most interesting consumer regrets from
our audience here are some hints that
list includes wedding dresses gym
memberships botox pelotons cars pets
homes paper planners and much more also
why are the minimalists considering
leaving social media altogether
plus a million more questions for the
minimalist and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast this week visit
patreon.com the minimalist to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
weekly private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
access to hundreds of hours of private
archives recordings of live events
exclusive home tours and our private
community
of thousands of open-minded minimizers
like you
you can follow the minimalists on tick
tock instagram facebook and twitter at
the minimalists if you want our podcast
show notes in your inbox just sign up
for our email list over at the
minimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team
i'm joshua fields milburn if you live
here today with
just one message
let it be this
[Music]
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it
everybody